un grito de alarma televisado en una
entrevista con la bbc el presidente
ucraniano insistió en La amenaza nuclear
rusa Ellos están empezando a preparar a
la sociedad es algo muy peligroso ellos
no están listos para usarla pero están
comenzando a comunicarlo
qué quiere decir con preparar a la
sociedad para usar un arma nuclear
Ellos no saben si van a usarla o no
usarla creo que es peligroso incluso
hablar del tema
pasando a hablar en ucraniano pidió a
los líderes mundiales que actúen antes
de que sea tarde
tenemos que actuar ahora no tenemos que
esperar los riesgos de más adelante
estoy de acuerdo esto es la Armagedón
el uso de la palabra Armagedón fue
deliberado una referencia a los
comentarios del jueves del presidente
estadounidense quien declaró que el
mundo Nunca había estado tan cerca de la
aniquilación nuclear desde 19
mairena aseguró que el mundo no se había
enfrentado a la posibilidad del
Armagedón desde la crisis de los misiles
de Cuba y añadió que había una
posibilidad real de que las armas
nucleares fueran usadas esta vez la
advertencia de vaiden cogió la Casa
Blanca por sorpresa y al día siguiente
los funcionarios intentaron rebajar el
tono del comentario del presidente la
administración aseguró que no tienen
pruebas de que el presidente ruso se
prepare para usar armas nucleares sin
embargo Putin ha avisado en repetidas
ocasiones que usará todos los recursos
necesarios para proteger el territorio
Ruso y en las últimas semanas el
ejército ucraniano ha recuperado terreno
haciendo retroceder a las fuerzas de
Moscú casi 2.500 kilómetros cuadrados
según celenski kiev incluso ha roto la
línea de defensa rusa en gerson una de
las cuatro regiones anexadas que el
kremlin ya considera parte de Rusia